hi Brian what are you doing I want you
to come Trum mot no Brian you're so sexy
I'm I I'm I'm going to Thailand to do
White Lotus and oh Mike White no Mike
doesn't talk like this oh oh you're so
beautiful great yeah yes yes you're such
a great you're so handsome oh I got you
yes Brian what are we what are you doing
later
[Laughter]
blanking on her name that's the thing
all right but we know we get the idea
yeah I can't go on doing this horrible
impersonation it's Jennifer kulage
Groundlings went to the Groundlings
Brian I know I forgot the name train
improvisation tongue oh yeah do I go
shopping now or does someone do that for
me very good is that yeah you obviously
had a writer